a woman can have equal respect to a man
if she is very good at being a woman and
a man gets respect for being very good
at being a man when a woman decides she
wants to act like a man or a man wants
act like a woman that's where all gets
[__] up we try to pretend that's what
I'm saying it's not the same men and
women are good at different things we
have different strengths different
weaknesses there's nothing wrong with
accepting that there's nothing wrong
with saying I'm a woman I'm good at X
he's a man who's good at why then we
work together as a team we have a
beautiful family we're happy forever
it's only confused where you have women
who sit and go no because in the name of
equality we can fight and work there's
no [__] women on the front line in
Ukraine that is silent [__] they put
some chick there dancing around doing
Pokemon dancers to try and convince men
to go [__] die in a ditch it's
garbage if you go to the front line of
Ukraine right now you do not see women
in their makeup and their manicures you
see [__] men